[Música]
Bienvenidos a directo cop 27 este
espacio especial en el que profundizamos
en los temas que se discuten en la
conferencia climática de Naciones Unidas
que se lleva a cabo en la ciudad egipcia
de charmal cada día hay una o varias
temáticas en las que se concentran las
discusiones y hoy los protagonistas
fueron los jóvenes además de la ciencia
y la resiliencia para hablar de este
último tema conectamos con María Clara
calle enviada especial a esta Cumbre que
se encuentra con una invitada especial
Buenas tardes María Clara de quién se
trata
estamos con Celia Shakira va Ella es la
primera mujer indígena en ser diputada
federal del estado de Minas gerais en
Brasil además a partir del 2023 se unirá
a los cuatro indígenas que hacen parte
de la cámara también en este país
Celia Gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en France 24 y bueno hoy es el Día
de la resiliencia y resiliencia
climática es poder enfrentar un
ecosistema que tenga algunas
dificultades Y quién mejor para esto que
los indígenas de hecho la bancada doctor
que conforman precisamente el Movimiento
Político que impulsó a Celia para llegar
como diputada va en contra de los
ruralistas y sus dos primeras misiones
son la democratización de los
territorios y la defensa de los derechos
de la selva Celia que aprender de los
indígenas para ser resilientes
necesita
resistencia nuestros pueblos indígenas
han estado en Brasil 522 años de lucha y
resistencia es un país que nos pregunta
si somos de verdad y que no reconoce que
la colonización no fue pacífica porque
Brasil ha violado a sus mujeres
indígenas a sus mujeres negras había
hablado a las mujeres indígenas y ahora
están violando la tierra Entonces qué
aprender de los pueblos indígenas
aprender de un pueblo que lleva 522 años
sin Rendirse sino que por el contrario
continuamos viviendo y principalmente
cuidando la tierra el día que los
pueblos indígenas den su último respiro
la humanidad tampoco podrá respirar más
ahora si bien también es por nuestras
indígenas tenemos un desafío no solo de
reforestar sino también de reforestar a
las personas a las personas en su cabeza
y en su corazón
un planeta sin contrates matado una
cabeza y un corazón
y no solo reforestar a las personas sino
que usted también ha hablado de
reforestar la política volver la mujer y
volverla indígena Cómo hacer eso no es
fácil
pintamos nuestro cuerpo porque el
racismo trae ausencia cuando no somos
víctimas del racismo somos Víctimas de
un racismo de un Brasil que aunque
comenzó con nosotros siempre nos negó no
existe un Brasil y nunca Existirá si la
presencia de nuestros pueblos indígenas
y las mujeres indígenas reforestamos la
política porque en este momento nuestra
lucha no es solo por reforestar sino
principalmente para no deforestar no es
para curar sino para no enfermarse
estamos mujerizando porque contra un
proyecto de destrucción de deforestación
y de minería solo las mujeres pueden
lograrlo estamos indigenizando Porque no
solo somos activistas ambientales es
nuestro modo de vida reforestar es
urgente reforestar la tierra el
pensamiento y el modo en el que las
personas ejercen la política porque la
política significa ciencia de gobernar y
no existe ciencia de gobernar sin
escuchar a las personas y a las mujeres
y muy brevemente ahora que habla de la
política ustedes esperan algún cambio
ahora que Lula da Silva será el nuevo
presidente de Brasil sí esperamos
transformación y ahora
sí esperamos transformaciones y ahora es
ahora no podemos esperar ustedes esperan
para cuidar a sus madres ustedes esperan
cuando su hijo está amenazado de muerte
ustedes esperan cuando el planeta no
está bien Ahora es ahora y una misión un
gesto importante que Lula puede hacer es
que en sus primeros 100 días de gobierno
de marque 5 territorios indígenas que
están en procesos jurídicos todos
autorizados sin impedimento alguno y
puede ser una misión que sirve no solo a
los Indígenas sino al mundo porque
defender el territorio es defender el
planeta no quedará selva en pies
indígenas no quedará selva en pies y
nuestras manos siguen cruzadas no
quedará selva en pie sin la demarcación
de los territorios indígenas
Celia Gracias por estar con nosotros y
ustedes continúen con más en francés 24
Pues a María Clara Muchas gracias por
este informe y a ustedes por su sintonía
continúan con nuestra programación aquí
en France 24
[Música]